we will now study a problem which is
quite difficult to approach in a direct
brute-force manner but becomes tractable
once we break it down into simpler
pieces using several of the tricks that
we have learned so far and this problem
will also be a good opportunity for
reviewing some of the tricks and
techniques that we have developed the
problem is the following there are n
people and let's say for the purpose of
illustration that we have three people
persons 1 2 & 3 and each person has a
hat they throw their hats inside a box
and then each person picks a hat at
random out of that box
so here are the three hats and one
possible outcome of this experiment is
that person 1 ends up with hat number
two person two ends up with hat number 1
and person 3 ends up we had number three
we could indicate the hats that each
person got by noting the here the
numbers associated with each person the
hat numbers and notice that this
sequence of numbers which is a
description of the outcome of the
experiment is just a permutation of the
numbers 1 2 3 of the hats
so we permute the hat numbers so that we
can place them next to the person that
got each one of the hats in particular
we have n factorial possible outcomes
this is the number of possible
permutations what does it mean to pick
hats at random one interpretation is
that every permutation is equally likely
and since we have n factorial
permutations each permutation will have
a probability of 1 over N factorial but
there is another way of describing
model which is the following person one
gets a hat at random out of the three
available then persons two gets a hat at
random out of the remaining hats then
person three gets the remaining hat each
time that there is a choice each one of
the available hats is equally likely to
be picked as any other hat let us
calculate the probability let's say that
this particular permutation gets
materialized the probability that person
one yet hat number two is one-third then
we're left with two hats person two has
two hats to choose from the probability
that it picks this particular hat is
going to be one-half and finally person
three has only one hat available so it
will be picked with probability one so
the probability of this particular
permutation is one over three factorial
but you can repeat this argument and
consider any other permutation and you
will always be getting the same answer
any particular permutation has the same
probability one over three factorial the
same argument goes through for the case
of general N and people and n hats and
we will find that any permutation will
have the same probability one over N
factorial therefore the process of
picking one hat at a time is
probabilistically identical to a model
in which we simply state that all
permutations are equally likely now that
we have described our model and our
process and the associated probabilities
let us consider the question we want to
answer let X be the number of people who
get their own hat back for example for
the outcome that we have drawn here the
only person who gets their own hat back
is person 3 and so in this case X
happens to take the value of 1
what we want to do is to calculate the
expected value of the random variable X
the problem is difficult because if you
try to calculate the PMF of the random
variable X and then use the definition
of the expectation to calculate this sum
you will run into big difficulties
calculating this quantity the PMF of X
is difficult and it is difficult because
there is no simple expression that
describes it so we need to do something
more intelligent find some other way of
approaching the problem the trick that
we will use is to employ indicator
variables let X I be equal to 1 if
person I selects their own hat and 0
otherwise so then each one of the excise
is 1 whenever a person has selected
their own hat and by adding all the ones
that we may get we obtain the total
number of people who have selected their
own hats this makes things easier
because now to calculate the expected
value of X it's sufficient to calculate
the expected value of each one of those
terms and add the expected values which
were allowed to do because of linearity
so let us look at a typical term here
what is the expected value of x I if you
consider the first description of our
model all permutations are equally
likely this description is symmetric
with respect to all the persons so the
expected value of X I should be the same
as the expected value of x1 now to
calculate the expected value of x1 we
will consider the sequential description
of the process in which one is the first
person to pick a hat now since x1 is a
Bernoulli random variable that takes
values 0 or 1 the expected value of x1
is just the probability that X
one is equal to one and if person one is
the first one to choose a hat that
person has probability 1 over n of
obtaining the correct hat so each one of
these random variables has an expected
value of 1 over n the expected value of
x by linearity is going to be the sum of
the expected values there is n of them
each expected value is 1 over N and so
the final answer is 1 this is the
expected value of the random variable X
let us now move and try to calculate a
more difficult quantity namely the
variance of X how shall we proceed
things would be easiest if the random
variables X I were independent because
in that case the variance of X would be
the sum of the variances of the x i's
but are the X is independent let us
consider a special case suppose that we
only have two persons and that I told
you that the first person got their own
hat back in that case the second person
must have also gotten their own hat back
if on the other hand person 1 did not
get their own hat back then person 2
will not get their own hat back either
because in this scenario person one gets
hat too and that means that person two
gets hot one so we see that knowing the
value of the random variable X 1 tells
us a lot about the value of the random
variable X 2 and that means that the
random variables X 1 and X 2 are
dependent more generally if I were to
tell you that the
first and -1 people got their own hats
back then the last remaining person will
have his or her own hat available to be
picked that's going to be the only
available hat and then person and will
also get their hat back so we see that
information about some of the excise
gives us information about the remaining
X and and again this means that the
random variables are dependent since we
do not have independence we cannot find
the variance by just adding the
variances of the different random
variables but we need to do a lot more
work in that direction in general
whenever we need to calculate variances
it is usually simpler to carry out the
calculation using this alternative form
for the variance so let us start towards
a calculation of the expected value of x
squared now the random variable x
squared by simple algebra is this
expression times itself and by expanding
the product we get all sorts of cross
terms some of these cross terms will be
of the type X 1 times X 1 or X 2 times X
2 these will be terms of this form and
there is n of them and then we get cross
terms such as X 1 times X 2 X 1 times X
3 X 2 times X 1 and so on how many terms
do we have here well if we have n terms
multiplying another terms we have a
total of n squared terms and are already
here so the remaining terms which are
the cross terms will be N squared minus
n or in a simpler form it's n times n
minus 1 so now how are we going to
calculate the expected value of x
squared well we will use linearity of
expectations so we need to calculate the
expected value of x I squared and we
also need to calculate
the expected value of x IX J when I is
different from J let us start with X I
squared first if we use the symmetric
description of our model all
permutations are equally likely then all
persons play the same role there's
symmetry in the problem so X I squared
has the same distribution as x1 squared
then x1 is a zero one random variable a
Bernoulli random variable so x1 squared
will always take the same numerical
value as the random variable x1 this is
a very special case which happens only
because a random variable takes values
in 0 1 & 0 squared is the same 0 1
squared is the same as 1 this expected
value is something that we have already
calculated and it is 1 over N let us now
move to the calculation of the
expectation of a typical term inside
this song so let a be different than J
and look at the expected value of X I XJ
once more because of the symmetry of the
probabilistic model it doesn't matter
which I and J we are considering so we
might as well consider the product of x1
with x2 now x1 and x2 take values 0 and
1 and the product of the two also takes
values 0 and 1 so this is a Bernoulli
random variable and so the expectation
of that random variable is just the
probability that this random variable is
equal to 1 but for the product to be
equal to 1 the only way that this can
happen is if both of these random
variables happen to be equal to 1 let us
now turn to the sequential description
of the
the probability that the first person
gets their own hot bath and the second
person gets her own hot back
he's the probability that the first one
gets their own hat back and then
multiplied by the conditional
probability that the second person gets
their own hat back given that the first
person got their own hat back
what are these probabilities the
probability that the person gets their
own hat back is one over n given that
person one got their own hat back person
two is faced with a situation where
there are n minus one available hats and
one of those is that person's hat so the
probability that person two will also
pick his or her own hat is one over n
minus one now we are in a position to
calculate the expected value of x
squared the expected value of x squared
consists of the sum of n expected values
each one of which is equal to 1 over n
plus so many expected values because we
have so many terms each one of which by
this calculation is 1 over n times 1
over n minus 1 and we see that we get
cancellations here and we obtain 1 plus
1 which is equal to 2 on the other hand
we have this term that we need to
subtract we found previously that the
expected value of x is equal to 1 so we
need to subtract 1 and the final answer
to our problem is that the variance of X
is also equal to 1
so what we saw in this problem is that
we can deal with quite complicated
models but by breaking them down into
more manageable pieces first breakdown
the random variable X as a sum of
different random variables then taking
the square of this and break it down
into a number of different terms and
then by considering one term at a time
we can often end up with the solutions
or the answers to problems that would
have been otherwise quite difficult